this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this subdued Sunday sunset Safari
it's the glorious afternoon here in the
western fringes of the great Kruger
National Park in South Africa my name is
James Henry there we go and over there
we have an Impala and filming that
Impala we have got Craig the Batman he's
lost the Impala now I have as well I
think he's behind the bush we were told
earlier by our security detail Herbert
cause are standing over there you see
nificent man that he is that we should
leave the Impala alone because he's
under stress that of course is true the
impala are under tremendous amount of
stress at the moment given that they're
rushing and trying desperately to set up
territories that will be acceptable to
the great bevy of wives they wish to
attract please do talk us using the
hashtag safe I live on Twitter and of
course the chat stream on YouTube it
would be wonderful to hear from you
during the course of this afternoon I
find myself often walking on Sunday
afternoons I've now got something stuck
up my pants but that shouldn't worry you
and I like to walk on the Sunday
afternoon because of course it's what
one should do on a Sunday afternoon the
Sun is out the sky is blue and birds are
chipping away yeah well done well as it
might be it's very pleasant to be out
here on foot on a Sunday afternoon that
will be with you until 6 o'clock
probably tomorrow plus five on bush walk
but now I wish to hand you over to the
finest specimen of humanity that East
Africa has ever produced a mr. David
Quito
hello everyone and look at me and
anybody who saw me eight nine hours ago
this money one two three four five
layers and a blanket on top of myself
huge difference the temperatures of
James might have said have doubled to
about 30 degrees Celsius 80-something
odds Fahrenheit look at those
temperatures and what you heard this
morning it's a huge difference the
temperatures have gone up and my number
of layers and me have gone down
I have only one layer at the moment what
a bill world some amount so many people
will be leaving this block build by the
termites and you could have Malta
lizards in here schoolers who live in
here and sometimes even snakes and
without notes I have to go back to the
car a very big welcome to all of you and
remember to keep in touch with us on
Twitter hashtags are alive and on the
YouTube chart
tell us your feelings what you'd like to
see and ask us as many questions as you
can
my plants are this morning I will be the
same loop I did earlier as I just jump
in the car what I did is in this morning
what happens in the wilderness you might
take a particular truck one way and see
nothing and maybe come back the same way
and see lots of stuff so I'm not worried
that towards I did in the morning might
still be a bit quiet you never know what
could be happening there so you're going
to take the same truck as I did this
morning and see what will be there all
right with me today is my very good
friend Sebastian he's on camera yes and
he does such a great job on camera Leah
you're very welcome son and yeah nice
what one of you on board let's see how
are they will be sorry casting doulas
what sir what was her name George thank
you very much and good to hear you love
my belt yes this is a beaded belt and
it's made by a tribe in Kenya called the
Masai people I'm happy you liked my belt
and maybe one day if you come on safari
with us I'll get you one
all righty and as Jen said earlier we
also have another gentleman who is on
full drive like me and his name is Steve
thank you David thank you David and
welcome all of you to the show again
beautiful afternoon here in the sabi
sands South Africa my name is the Falcon
rich I'm joined on camera by Thomas Ito
otherwise known as David and we are out
in search of everything wonderful and
marvelous obviously that is what we do I
share we talk about things marvelous let
me show you beautiful things and we
would like to find some cats because
apparently this morning nothing was
found told tracks tracks and tracks and
that's all there was but I was nosing
around over there and I stuck my head in
the Fallen marilla like what I found the
beak of a hornbill very very cool now
handles like to nest in cavities of
trees and it's possible that maybe it
died in there it's not a fully mature
beak it's quite small but maybe there
was a youngster in there when the tree
fell over maybe it was killed by its
sibling sometimes it happens because
horn balls have got something known as a
sink synchronistic breeding so in there
lay their first egg they start hatching
it so once the first egg is laid they
start hatching and then the next day
they lay another egg and then the next
day and other egg and so you get this
stage of development where the first one
hatches first takes more food than the
sicker went and the more than the third
and if it's a year of plenty of food all
through do well but if it's you of low
food then one of them is not going to do
very well in this Marilla has definitely
fallen down more than a season ago so
maybe it happened during the drought I'm
not sure I wasn't here I've only been
here since January but marvelous
nonetheless and my scratching is
continued now is actually going to do a
little tree quiz with you this afternoon
but look at what I found on this branch
here can you see Eddie's Racha in front
of my finger Dave it looks like a stick
it is an insect of sorts it is
unbelievably camouflaged
I wonder if any of you insect lovers up
there can take a screenshot and tell me
what it is I've I've never seen
something like this it's not a stick
insect but it's a stick like insect
which looks just like the planter you
get in that can you see that it's an
insect I was blown away it moved when I
cut the branch off
it's a barking sect cursed is it okay
bark insect that's Kirsten from FCS
summary bark insects so let's see if
anyone else up there can hashtag so far
alive or to comments on the YouTube
stream what insects is this but I'm
gonna go put it back on the tree in a
moment but first I wanted to see if any
of you out there can tell me what tree
this is hashtag Safari live it is a very
common tree those of you out there I
have spoken about this I am gonna get
back on to my tree vibes to see if
you've all been listening and this tree
is marvelous for is it working there
this tree is marvelous if you break the
leaves off you can make a lovely tea so
an animal that would like to eat these
leaves David's got one of them so let's
go over there right and I'm sure all of
you have seen this antelope here many
times on your screen brought to us and
I'll give you my first quiz today and
anybody who would tell me what these
animals
I'll give him oh ha some big applause
and claps from Africa and just simple
coos he is a ruminant as you can see him
there and he is regarded hitting and
chewing cud look at the huge fringe hair
that he got on the neck on the duel up
there and the spots on the face very
good job there and as a female just
passing in front of him so anybody who'd
be able to tell me the species or the
type of antelope we got here as usual
Twitter hashtag Safari live and there's
one female running behind him I'm not
sure he wanted she wanted a spoke or two
him let's see what the female wants to
do there and the two females there
calmly you get it right and I can haul I
hope you hear my clubs all the way from
Africa well done well done to all of
them well done you must have been very
good view of us well well done and yes
is cool
and precisely there greater kudu well
done I'll give you another cruise much
later maybe this time get a bad species
for you instead of an antelope I think
that was so easy right give you
something tough and will not try see
yeah the male kudu is moving following
that females there and they do not know
whether they had an issue between them
and the males is slowly following them
with some bad on top of its buck getting
a hitchhike but ideally those bass there
will get the parasites out of the bodies
and that is what is called red-billed
oxpecker red bill oxpecker and what's
the male slowly walks away we'll also
try yeah it's coming out again those two
females there they were going for each
other I do not know Hawaii sometimes you
know females will have an issue of a
male's which rarely happens is normal
emails that fight over females and
baying browsers in general you will see
the only eating leaves because mainly
the kudos browsers
he got huge rock hormones Charlie I hope
you agree there are huge ones where I
come from when you see the kudos when
they would naturally die people would
make or people would get the horns and
they would make some very nice musical
instruments and you'd play music like
you know a flute and we'll play the
music during wedding ceremonies in the
background I'm not sure you can hear
there's some Mill impalas rutting and
snorting and making all this right
cause the females there now the number
is growing up
we've got four we had initially - and
the Ox because we'll still keep busy in
getting the ticks and the parasites out
of the bodies so what you see them doing
now is they're not chewing or they just
eat the cheat a little bit
follow it and regurgitate a letter and
riku it much finer because they go for
chamber stomachs the kuru or most
ruminants and because of the heat of the
day you notice they're enjoying some
very nice shade from where they are
eating
and the quizzes continue and Stephen
schewe
is waiting to get his answers I am
indeed how is everybody this afternoon
and did you manage to come up with
anything on Mari quiz wasn't the best
sample but that is the way it works such
there were no fruits there were no
flowers there were seeds Michelle no it
was not a maroon I'll show you once
again just so that we're clear this is a
simple leaf plant pea heart no it's not
it's amber tea there's simple leaves
that are oppositely arranged you can see
there's one on that side one on that
side and a very characteristic leaf
twist James you're in the right sort of
family but the wrong tree this twist on
the tip of the of the of the leaf here
is what gives it away
very nice twist over there and these
trees occur what we would say high up on
the slope because they like to pump lots
of moisture up from the roots down deep
and they're losing their leaves soon
they have got fruits and pods around but
I haven't shown you them so James you
are very close but we were not correct
sir if we give another few minutes now
that I've given away the twist in the
leaf very characteristic
and that with these trees you find them
on the top of the slope where we are
here and there's no there's no thorns in
the trees stick stick mantis Catherine
okay it didn't seem to have any sort of
mantis type sort of appendages but I
need to maybe have a look at that
screenshots again I've never seen
anything like that before he was very
new but when we look up on the slope
here the the trees have got large leaves
to pump the water from the bottom and we
don't have too many thorny trees up here
because they don't really want to slow
down the feeding from herbivores they
mainly have tannin in them to prevent
them being eaten by insects and as you
saw that insect on the plant itself was
there and if we look at this tree over
here the branch the leaf it's been
munched away there by some form of
Caterpillar
so no thorns up on the slope you mainly
find the thorns down on the bottom where
the browsing is a lot sweeter and tastes
a lot better when up on the top you've
generally found more chemicals and if we
look just left of us you can kind of see
a band of solver cluster leaves and I'm
not going to eat one of them again no
matter how nicely anybody asks me to
remember Brent the Aerosmith's challenge
I still haven't gotten him back for that
he challenged me to eat a leaf and it's
loaded with tenon and chemicals project
alpha twig start bug that sounds about
right
projects alpha never seen one before but
thank you twig snapped bug send those
through on Twitter with the screenshots
so I can save them for later reference
projects offer that does sound about
right anyway if you made that up well
done whoa
Matt it's not a worry we are on top of
the slope we found glories normally at
the bottom loads down way down at the
bottom I will find you a glory though I
love how I've got everybody guessing
lots of names remember that son Bertie
right at the bottom the jackal berry
right at the bottom those occur in the
drainage we're on top of the Catena
right now folks so very common and I'm
going to give it away
are you ready for its dun dun dun the
big reveal
this is the red bush willow the most
common tree we find up on the top of the
slope here and this is called mixed bush
willow felt very common tree up here
come Britain a pickle Adam is the
species name because the apex of the
leaf let me show you a pic you lots of
means to have a twist in the apex right
over there so that is the dead giveaway
for the tree and all the bush willows
have got this double leaf so they're
opposite and nearly these leaves are far
larger than the russet bush willow and
the rest bush willow a general generally
have growing down at the bottom and so
not the same but the same family Richard
so very very similar but the leaves are
very very big these but that's about
three inches or so whereas the russet
Bush willows probably only about that
big in size and rounded at the top okay
very good very good everybody's awake
now now we can do a hard one so let's go
over the bush walk team and see what
interesting information James is going
to impart well I was trying to find
something interesting to impart to you
at the moment
I thought about doing a sarcastic tree
quiz by doing something like this what
tree is that but then I thought some of
you were in find the sock hasn't been
amusing side I didn't do that
let's carry on Kirsten says that Salif
who sees people like her that I was
worried about you know I thought about
my tree quiz anyway we've come almost to
the far northern fringes of Jummah where
we're hoping to pick up on tracks of the
Minka Puma pride from this morning we
may or may not be lucky who knows but
what we have here Craig is some cotton
wool that is growing in a plant a grass
of some sort
what is that let us investigate and find
out for I have no doubt that all people
around the world watching this broadcast
and I'll saw amazed
perhaps a spider is it perhaps a mmm
hibiscus seed caught up can I pull it
towards myself pray thank you so much
now it's been tied together very
deliberately didn't exactly what it is
those are the seeds I don't see the
seasons across and I'm not gonna destroy
it there's a spider inside there or
something inside there it's leave it
alone I don't know what it is but that's
been produced by an animal absolutely no
idea could have been a spider
perhaps a small caterpillar
it is very very thick anyway it's
sitting on the tips of a tuft of guinea
grass or panicum maximum this is the
kind of place well you've quite like to
spend the rest of your afternoon I tell
you looking at the waving combs and
seeds as the Sun Goes Down
wouldn't you Craig yes Craig's is all
right I believe that this segment is
going to finish now because Kirsten says
we're going to go to David who can
actually find an animal
right yes said after the segment there
and we got something
or we could some antelopes that we do
not have in Kenya and this is the Nala
or this annulus and apparently in the
whole of East Africa we do not have
vanilla females as in most antelopes
you'll have the females without horns
and the nails of the horns and this
Neela's here also do not have horns and
am people exactly the last few days
every time I've seen onion on a drive
because back home in East Africa where I
come from the Nala
do not exist will move for a little bit
see whether you can capture the a little
bit more on the left here let's see Savi
we can get the ones on the left again so
there and this young male cones are just
starting to pop up
and the stripes not very different from
like what you see in the kudu and also
them being exclusively browsers but once
the whole like you see there you'll see
them foraging on the ground looking for
small low hubs if you want trying to
cross the road there Seb sorry to look
at them
consider Christian is do they have the
same number of stripes only afar I'm
sorry I am NOT a hundred percent sure of
that answer I might want to find out but
if I would want to compare that question
to a question I would get in Kenya say
about the Zebras with your stripes how
they see the Zebras got different
stripes no one zebra is like the other
I'll find out later on and know if the
stripes will be the same number here for
the annales I'll find out and I'll let
you maybe know if not today definitely
tomorrow a huge male also was trying to
curse there I'm not sure whether the
male won't come and join the females
here it's just pop for a little bit so
they can get the male equally huge
nothing big
like the male could be so earlier
kirinda you say you confess little [ __ ]
between Kudo and Daniela and now if you
look carefully now you can see the
difference the femurs here are a little
bit like brown chestnut in color and the
kudu
I would say they're more Brown the
male's of the nail are not as big and
their homes if you look the one walking
away there it's not as spiral as we saw
before with a kudu and I'll show you
later on
just keep enjoying that view there and
I'll show you how the males of the kuru
would be very very different off to you
so the male we had before if not I'll
show you and you see why they are quite
different the two species are quite
different
Aravinda
all right Sam
Sourav inda look at the size of that
hunter up there and that's the greater
kudu and you can tell or you can see the
horns are huge and you see they are all
very very spiral I like the yellows that
don't take all those twists and turns
this rock of horns here are huge
the massive sorry if you have some glare
there but shoot me now I'm gonna show
you how and Yanis male horns look like
and you see they're quite different
apart right Ravinder hopefully you see
the difference there I said if you can
show them now you'll see that's a male
yalla and see this have only say one
twist that's it if you look at the
amount of the fringe here the Nala has
all the way from the neck to the abdomen
it considers a huge difference between
the two and Ravinder yes you are very
welcome thank you for like you know that
you've seen the difference you're very
very welcome or vinda right and we'll
move on and hopefully we'll see more of
the crews more the dollars and the
difference will still keep playing out
right now forgetting the crews hours
equally heavier than the knowledge
as we kept truckin here on for Hulan
where a gentleman who is on two wheel
and let's find out what he's doing well
what we have here every body is the same
plant that I found the other day in dem
very kindly we have a suggestion from
Judy H solanum Tom Antos M synonymous
with Solanum Bocelli I didn't remember
that I'm actually reading it Solanum
Bocelli I synonymous with solanum the
other word I've not forgotten one second
salon toe meant awesome
so Judy H I and I had a Sabri f--
discussion on the tweets tweet about
whether or not this was in fact the case
because it's not always a spiny plant
and I found it the other day not with
nearly this many fruits on it and that's
how Judy H managed to identify it and
I'm not convinced that she's in fact
correct as usual this is it is solanum
virtually a high cost element ozon now
as we got here Craig said to me he said
that looks like a tomato and so I said
Greg yes it does look like tomato
because indeed it is thought of the same
family it is the deadly nightshade
family to which of course the aubergine
and the peppers belong yes does the
tomato potato and the poison apple here
and in this solanum Craig would you like
to eat this tomatoes look nice hmm
Cody I'm gonna say no you can't eat them
because I think that although they look
like Tomatoes many of these are the
flowers here all of the plants related
to the deadly nightshade are quite toxic
and so I'm not going to eat this and
often the orange ones are toxic I don't
know why that is the case but you can
see it really does look like a miniature
tomato Bush this was not quite as thorny
as the other one but
has got some nasty spines on it Carol
and you say you like the colors be nice
to plant um yeah the colors are quite
nice I know what the flowers look like
now you should have been asked to paint
not plant yes I think it will be nice to
paint it's got a smell about it not
unlike a tomato bush which I don't
there's not a particularly nice smell I
don't think anyway then also here I'm
going to pick this thing a piece of the
flower that keeps on giving that is of
course the little beetles the wharf area
sorry the wall period indica you see
them Greg very sweet little black and
white bee gees I know what kind they are
they're only about two millimeters
across and they're devouring the small
leaves at the top of solanum not solanum
of the wharf area just put that one back
there they might survive into adulthood
they have decimated the small plant but
isn't the solanum fantastic I'm very
grateful Judy H thank you very much for
identifying food you know Katmandu
if you look around where I am sitting
over here you can see that the grafts is
no longer particularly green it's taken
on a sort of goldish hue and that is
typical of the drier season so yes it is
getting drier certainly it's noticeable
in the grass but there's still plenty of
good forage for the animals out here so
I didn't think they have anything to
worry about from a forage point of view
and it's been a very good rain season so
I don't see that there's going to be any
particular shortage going into the
summer I mean yes little vivid rough
come over September but after that it
should be fun
so I think everything is in pretty good
shape at the moment for well pretty good
shape for an easy winter for most of the
animals so that in summary Solanum
Bocelli i or solanum tormentors and
synonymous with each other those two and
magnificent example of the deadly
nightshade family okay Steven is now
taking over the mantle I see from Brent
Leo Smith and he is the quiz master in
chief did James just call me the chief
I'm very proud James never said
something so nice to me before
well we are on the western side we've
had tracks of the uncle homers that they
were following up on this morning and
while I'm here actually that's a lovely
tree there's two lovely trees here for
those who got a little bit confused with
the trees earlier but we're looking at
tracks and the big tree you're looking
at now is a jackal berry is a marvelous
big specimen very long elliptical sorry
lanceolate leaves without the twist and
they're generally occur around water a
good indicator of water in fact and then
someone who guessed jackal berry that is
the jackal berry and then behind Davi
you know the Guara just here one of
David's favorite trees this is in fact
the hairy guar II they're also very very
evergreen long greeny leaves you can
confuse the jackal berry and the hairy
guar quite easily but do not confuse
them with the red bush willow that we
saw earlier much rounder and broader
leaves not the same sort of greenness
either the scent they've got a bit more
yellow to them and these two plants here
are indicating that there's some form of
moisture in the undergrowth but we've
just come on to the western side to see
where the tracks of the Oklahoma's might
have gotten to and I've been chatting
with her be on the radio he's with the
bush war team and the tracks have come
to here but that happened crossed over
so we had to go back again and see if we
can give or help Toby and James aren't
far away so we're gonna
see what they come up with but are we
gonna keep driving around we might go
dancing to have a look where there's
some water because we know lions like to
drink especially when it gets hot but it
doesn't appear as if they've gone west
across the boundary here which is great
so hopefully we can find them for you
but the bush walked in their tracks all
over the place from here this morning
but Herbie doesn't seem to think that
the Lions are gone they're here
somewhere
I think they must have just run out of
time I can see the big track there of
Brent Leo Smith who has now gone on
leave he looked very happy to be
departing I think he gets to see Jamie
in a few days
I'm sure that's another bonus
okay so liens could be anywhere in here
as I said the bushwalk team is out and
about and we are enthusiastic and we're
excited and I don't think in this
temperature the Lions are going to be
doing too much as you saw with James
Henry last night he spent some time with
them and only right towards the end of
Drive did their start movie that's just
typically the way it is so ideally we
need to find some fresh tracks and
curbing them are really close by so I'm
sure they're going to be back here soon
but I've got a feeling - the Lions are
in this block over here on the left and
marvelous indeed another tree that we
were getting confused with before this
one right next to us Davi the russet
bush willow you can see the leaves are
very very small and obviously I didn't
show you pods earlier but look at those
leaves they're almost the same size as
the pods themselves but they are very
round not very broad in their size so
lots and lots of trees are today and
this is definitely a tree that the crews
like to feed on side of the red bush
winners don't actually get very big
they're generally grow up as I set up on
the slopes and so they only experience a
wet season growth so they are probably
one of the hardest woods you find in the
area Nick they make phenomenal
phenomenal firewood not that that's the
only function but there are too much
resistance I'll show you a relatively
decent sized one but they don't get much
bigger than that they're only grow in
the wet season and they're cuz they high
up they lose moisture they drop the
leaves into through winter they're
completely dormant but they're related
to the led wood but the lead woods grow
down in the drainage lands so they're
growing all the time that's why they get
so much bigger
but anyone you ask a farmer any farm
will tell you the tree that grows at the
top of the hill produces the hardest
wood because it is growing in the wind
in the summer and then in the winter it
goes dormant so just lignified gets
harder and harder and harder ok well
let's go back to the bush Hawk team and
see if they've managed to find any
tracks and found a few tracks and we're
now in some fairly dense bush over here
and in that dense Bush were hoping we
might have flush their pride of lions
Herbert do you think we're going to
flush a pride of lions in so they killed
them Impala there last night we think
which is quite a long way from where
they were hunting make sure it's about a
kilometer or so surprised it took them
that long I'm also surprised that the
wildebeest survived their evening on
quarantine keyrings because the fact
that there's lions doesn't go for one of
them I think speaks volumes for their
kind of random approach they have to
hunt in anyway their tracks then we went
across our Western laundry and then came
back again we think so we're quite close
to the western boundary now and you can
just imagine how easy it would be for
lions to hide here and so we're just
stepping carefully you don't want to
give them a fright
mostly we don't want to give the frost
ourselves and we don't want to as
Herbert says dance too much today
that's what happens when you all know
step on lions
so hippies just checking on the ground
there only he will be able to see tracks
on grounders heart and see some things
walk there but what was in tell you now
one of the things that people are most
concerned about out here is whether or
not it's safe rashaam be is is safe this
is not a Red Bull sort of adrenalin
sport that we're doing yet oh hang on a
second I'll get back to you on this
Steve's got an interesting bird we do we
found ourselves a southern white crown
Shrike and you can clearly see the tip
of the beak is very very sharp a very
characteristic feature of the lenio or
Shrike family and this is one of the
cooperative breeding strikes and easily
seen by that white crest all the helmet
should I say always generally found in
groups I don't know where his family is
maybe they're out foraging this one
stayed home for a bit of a view but they
are omnivores and will feed on on small
mammals even if they can lizards
potentially even small snakes but then
lots and lots of insects and the reason
all these strikes they are fall into the
what we called the butcherbird family as
I say omnivores but also predatory they
will use sharp spines and thorns to
impale their prey and enables them to to
then rip it apart they don't have a
strong foot like many of the Raptor
species that you find that will use the
foot obviously to to hold the prey as
they rip it apart they'll often impale
it on a spike very commonly seen with
barbed wire
it acts as a larder for advertising
territory advertising the ability to
provide food and it also assists in the
ripping much bigger prey if you've seen
the birds most birds they swallow their
prey whole but if you're a Shrike you
generally catch prey that's too big to
swallow holes you need to be able to use
some form of mechanism to assist in
tearing it apart marvelous how he's just
sitting there for us hey Dave I wonder
if he knows where the Lions have gotten
to this is a beautiful bird it goes and
I don't know if you could hear that that
noise it made as it flew off it sounds
like a squeaky toy that you give to your
dog and they squeak with their mouth
very easy to identify when you hear them
flying okay and on we go okay well seems
that bird has flown off let's go back to
here the end of James's tail bird so
know it's not dangerous out here and I
would
people often ask that as if we in some
way have an adrenaline junkies view on
life which of course great behind the
camera does but for the rest of us no
it's not it unsafe out here at all as
long as you're trained to deal with the
animals and you know what to do if you
see an animal so if we would have to
happen upon those Lions we know not to
run we don't stand still
I feel good to come across a buffalo
well you'd hopefully see it before it
saw you so we're always looking
carefully under every bush around every
tree just to make sure that we're not
not surprised by anything but mostly the
thing is that animals are afraid of us
as human beings on foot especially and
that's what makes us a relatively safe
operation you wouldn't be doing this in
an area where there were polar bears for
example which tend to CSS fair game you
wouldn't swim in a lake full of
crocodiles they also see us as fair game
and so you know it is in Africa it's
generally relatively safe as long as you
know what you're doing and of course as
long as you're out in the daytime
things change at night when you get
things like em lions and leopards and
hyenas are much more confident and they
can tell of course that we can't see
what's going on at night time you know
you stand around trip over things can't
see properly
and they pick that up immediately
we're heading towards a pan now little
pan of water over here spent beautiful
of the pan and perhaps the Lions stop
there for drink but perhaps a whole lot
else did as well is definitely a huge
amount of Impala activity through here
which would expect from a hot day like
this 30 degrees Celsius odd 18 degrees
was it's an 85 odd Fahrenheit
not bad for winter and we're now on a
major game part and this major game path
goes all the way up to dam just north of
us and that's called Sydney's dam
alright David has returned to piste and
he is now on cheated cut line
right we are still hunting for our cuts
this afternoon and most important also
learning the boundaries itself so I know
where I am and why I'm not
and we have seen a few trucks behind us
a few minutes ago and they just
disappeared they didn't look another
going forward or backwards very very
clearly and you're trying to find out
when it gets more fine sound we can
follow them again
and maybe they may lead us to something
interesting will Tran sing by any
watering hole around this area because
what's warm like this cats will either
very quickly go for a drink as it gets
hot as they you know dehydrate and it
will be good for us
trucks have lunch here they do magic
unlike in Kenya where you have physical
air to look for the animals here we do
the trucks so ginger you say you would
like to see a zebra hopefully you'll see
one and a rubber sternum sorry ginger
just ginger I hope I got Union correct
and you're saying you would like to see
a zebra I would be happy to see it but
you haven't seen one zebras who will be
maybe sharing our happiness and
celebration together as I see and you
see your zebra which I'm sure you might
have seen many before it's gonna be my
first dobrze to see here in South Africa
just let you know this what some
subspaces of each other here we have
what you call grant's zebra the ground
zebra and in east africa we have the
plains zebra very identical but the
patterns can be slightly different
yeah you know a subspecies of each other
ginge I do not know why you come from
whether you have zebras or not and I'd
be happy if you could also let me know
on Twitter or specifically you'd like to
see the zebra and not see any other
species and not see any other animal if
you heard me the other day you might
have gotten me saying I love zebras the
black and white colors my favorite
colors and anything black and white be
it clothes wear shoes hearts you know
any coach any jumper anything black and
whites I'll always go for it
still trying to look for any signs of
cuts and you never know and with this
very fine sand it's very very easy to
pick trucks and more so of leopards we
said the Newcomb Alliance yesterday so
today would be happy to see some mass
sported leopards and James got some
interesting amphibian we're just
discussing what these frogs are
everybody I don't know what they are and
who he was asking if that one stuck in
the mud there was actually stuck I don't
think it's stuck I think that wonder if
they have been actually sort of Easter
fighting under the mud there one day
lovely I've got no idea what they are
but I have a frog applicator on my door
that so I'll see if I can find out the
first thing we need to do is go to the
my location section so that they will
basically eliminate anything that isn't
here there's another one let me see the
other one no so there's a point with my
shadowed stick they're still there now
to me that looks like some kind of I
actually don't know what it is and it's
looking it looks a little bit like an
ornate frog but I'm pretty sure it's not
no nightfall doesn't have any green on
it River for now okay maybe a striped
stream frog
ah how about that a striped stream frog
yes I think that's what he is
and just check his distribution to make
sure I'm quite lucky I think it's
probably one of the stream frogs you
just put that in the stream [ __ ] oh they
make it call for you give this chat
responds hmm it's watching a fly oh yes
it might kill it you might have a live
killed everybody do you think he's going
to kill it
I'm also not sure and the advances on
striped stream frog I'm very happy to
take any ideas from all of you sitting
at home looking at our frog he's a
magnificent fellow you know we don't get
to look at folks like this he's too big
to be a reed frog but he shows no it's
just that you can't surely be the
standard-issue bubbling Cocina flight oh
my goodness this is fantastic
look at that it's a big fly come on frog
take that fly this is the most wonderful
always fern away
it's a pity
do you think this is a snapchat frog I'm
happy to look at that just snot-nose
trove let's keep watching him I don't
have snot-nosed frog in my on my app any
other name for a snot what do you
calling a snot-nosed frog penny still
looking just down through the list I
think that that's what it is I'm and
this it's got a very pointy nose our
sharp nursed frog project author you say
shop nosed frog that's actually a really
good call just looking at it now sharp
nose they have got a sharp nose he's got
yellow underneath his belly and a little
bit of red he's got a little bit of red
underneath his eye sharp nosed frog I'm
happy to go with us check the
distribution yes distribution is good
could easily be a shop nosed frog
actually well done
so he's a kind of a grass frog yes
that's actually much better isn't
differently not her that's a much better
sort of general look striped grass frog
he loses his stripes though on his body
doesn't he yeah I'm gonna go with a
striped sharp nosed frog that I project
off and I think you were you've done a
great job finding that
well apparently our sharpnose frog isn't
nearly as entertaining as a feeling bird
yeah well you got a bed it was sitting
in the open a moment ago now it's
flapped down into the cover of that
small gory bush you can just see the
very long tail on the screen there it
goes it's on the ground now yeah what's
it feeding on I wonder if any of you out
there I'd love to know the bird is
amongst their group
what bird is this hashtag Safari live
what bird is that black and white long
tail hmm probably munching on ants right
now and so termites most likely ants
because they're a little bit more active
in the heat of the day and by the way
it's moving around so quickly and
munching it's definitely a lot of little
things on the ground so I would assume
ants but it is another omnivore and is
related to the other bird we saw any
moments ago it's also cooperative
breeder it also falls under the family
but who can tell me has tags for alive
what bird is that
busy foraging not too bothered by the
formic acid that the ants might be
exuding as a defense mechanism
Ravinder it's actually way bigger than a
wider and we don't get any black and
white only wide as the waters have got a
little bit of color in them and even if
it's just the beak and this is probably
about three terms maybe twice twice as
big as a wider Angie you've got it
spot-on anybody else want to have a
guess before we announce Angie's
victorious a name for the bird well done
Ally well if those of you have correctly
identified it as the magpie Shrike
hundred percent to you and it is also
cooperative breeder as we said and for
some reason the cooperative breathers
all alone today
I don't know what's going on it is a
lonely
Sunday is it Sunday this Sunday yes it
is okay so we're going to go from one
species that spends time together to
another right the species changes now
and we have another one here and we got
some nice piggies around here and you
can see how when they want to reach the
grass they will live down to reach the
grass what hopes young female they'll
kill them and you notice carefully the
lonely is nil and what do we need to eat
the grass is because they'll use their
upper nose or muddy ball to be able to
scrub or to dig if they eating some
tubas there from the grass or rhizomes
and by so doing that gives them some
very good leverage on the head and the
neck and you can see one it's pretty wet
we've got some pan of water not very far
from where we are so must have been in
there because of the heat of the day it
was maybe trying to cool off very
interesting how you see them eating
kneeling what did the fluffy says hurry
Pumbaa alright fluffy yes
this is very good for agree with you yes
this is Pumbaa and most likely you must
have seen the movie Lion King fluffy
correction this is Pumbaa and look at
the big boy coming in behind there
and if you look carefully he got more
mud on the hind legs so he must have
been laying or wallowing the water on
the bumps I'd see the shiny left leg and
truly is Pumbaa you notice he is not
kneeling down I like the other young
ones swirling down eating he can
comfortably reach the dress and a big
boy is there an interesting to see them
you know feeding like that because some
of the big ones could be anything 60 or
like so kilograms and they're heavy
heavy and it's not commonly you'll see
you really see leopards coming for the
warthogs and what I want to do I really
like to see the big one he looks really
big with big you know testicles there we
won't try and get a little closer to him
and see whether it could get a little
bit more view of it cuz Pumas always
exciting pigs to watch let's just get a
little close and see how far they have
gone
and this pool of words not very far from
where we are and simply they go left to
right let's fight yeah yeah right here
it's interesting when they run the
females will go ahead and then the male
always come last and he was so much big
Bella is what I was saying earlier sorry
they're huge and some of them would be
anything like 65 70 80 kilos if you got
for our Hosanna chief here or the
leopards bringing them down because of
the size and how huge they are I would
still want to have one more look and see
if they're gonna set it down
Aiden that's a very good question and
you're asking why do they love to play
in the mud
number one is could be only for one
obvious reason well it gets hard to
remember I was talking about all the
temperatures have gone pretty high maybe
you know 80 plus degrees Fahrenheit over
30 plus I don't know what the two
bridges are Celsius that gets very very
hot and the only one way this water
cooled himself down is jumping in the
water and by so doing they'll be able to
cool off and sometimes on the jump in
the water also what should happen they
may come out with a lot of mud
Aiden on their bodies and that mud will
just cut their bodies like sunscreen and
watch it to do it will kill any
parasites that will be on the skin of
the Pumas or the warthogs it suffocates
them they're not able to breathe and
then they die and they just fall off so
for those two reasons that's why the
watch hogs will go in the mud they've
given us a good goodbye which was fine
that was a good show
and Steve is he is by a tree
yes we have found a beautiful specimen
of the red bush willow and I forget who
asked before but how big do they get
this is about as big a specimen as I
have ever seen it is enormous and it is
a beautiful tree have you hugged the
tree today you should it is beautiful
it's magical
I am officially and I will admit it I am
a tree hugger I'm not shy to admit it
beautiful specimen the red bush willow
growing here just above the slope the
saw the class leaf lion in front of me
there and we have another vehicle then I
parked in the road so I'm going to have
to move to get out of the way I do
apologize for my quick movements back to
the car now I have caused the traffic
jam when it's good David who's got a
magnificent animal
yes we just spotted one of the tallest
animals the tree got in Africa or the
tallest one in the world one minute we
get there
which said that my apologies and it's a
huge male giraffe and this is my first
giraffe I am seeing in Juma this is my
first giraffe to see in South Africa I'm
not sure it have a lesson or a big wound
in that area there it seems like it has
an infection I'm not sure ease of tango
a fungal disease some kind of skin
disease I'm sorry I don't close closely
with my binoculars and see and on the
other side of snake you can see the ox
because trying to get all the parasites
out carefully looking to investigate
very nice and I'm equally excited like
you seeing a giraffe for the first time
just I was talking about the zebra I'm
equally excited to see the giraffe for
the first time in South Africa I can't
I'm trying to the explore and find out
whether that would have been some fungal
infection or a wound of some kind but
I've noticed sometimes with some of
these animals as a move for a little bit
sir if you allow me we have seen some of
the ox speakers when they remove the
parasites from the Hobby boss there is a
place or the time to keep packing on a
particular area and if you can't
buffaloes on the faces buffer or
sometimes emits some to MUX below there
because the ticks we love to come on
this area below the buffaloes and they
have like they have other eyes kind of
stop right there right below them they
have little patches I'm not sure that
could be a case here but it's very
interesting
to know what could have happened there
have you seen the drug before Sebastian
yeah do you know what curve in the
problem thank you very much
Carsten think you said yes and you know
learning to do that tear it must been a
fight before and you know you realize
mils fight a lot and fight some terms
are very very fertile and the horns
maybe or the ossicles could have done
its damage I try and get a little closer
to it again because I'm really
interested to see that kind of wood and
try and calculate how that blow was that
even tore the skein of the dropper and
cuz it survived then I think it must
been very very lucky you imagine such a
giraffe with such a huge scar that's an
area without a doctor or without
medication medication but it must have
done very very well to have recovered
from attuned and unlike the would we
have been seeing on one of the lionesses
of the new kuma lionesses here
this one looks to be very well healed as
he majestically walks over there
that's you asking how would you tell the
age of Azeroth that could be a very
difficult question and I haven't done
that before but in general you'd look at
size size would help you more to tell
because if we talk of color sometimes
the colors could be misleading we have
seen some very odd jalath giraffes
looking very dark and samyamas also
looking very dark so it could be very
difficult to tell I do not you have an
idea how you tell the age of a giraffe
honestly for me I have no idea
completely but I would say any guesswork
out do I'll start by looking at the size
right II still have one more look on it
and then we'll get to looking for other
animals
child of the universe you are asking
whether I can tell the differences
between the giraffes of East Africa and
the giraffes here yes there are huge
differences I'll tell you and the only
way we tell different species of
giraffes is by the patterns on their
bodies we got four species of giraffes
in the world we have the southern
giraffes here in Kenya we have the Masai
giraffe and you realize the massage
giraffes are you look taller than this
ones and the patents are more well
developed than the patents that we just
saw there of the southern giraffe yes
the patent child of the universe is what
tells me the different species of
giraffes in Kenya we should go to
another type that's called the
reticulated giraffe which button of the
body looks like a fishing net a very
good question they are child of the
universe yes excited a giraffe for the
first time and this morning elephant sir
things are getting better cept for me
James who is walking is still looking
down well yes one last look down if one
is looking at something on the ground I
find that is the most helpful place to
be looking that was a yellow pansy let's
just see if he settles again please
settle again yellow pansy come on yellow
pansy settle immediately yes it and sit
and sit sit let's just wait for him to
city is a most beautiful butterfly all
there is look at that you got in there
Craig well done
reminds me of course at the older
English dog handler Barbara Woodhouse I
guess an early precursor to the years
what's that dog whispers name says or
someone anyway she used to say sit sit
and all the dogs would sit and say
that's what I've done to the butterfly
in hopes it will sit now of course it's
current resting position is much more
the norm for a butterfly normally there
is to their wings up and it is one of
the distinguishing features between
butterflies and moths moths will
normally register their bring wings down
so to have him sat on the ground of his
wings open like that is quite unusual
we're all our far western boundary now
and I think that these lions have
probably oh look at that
they're probably headed off into arrows
or someone beating these Lions and you
know we've found lots of small
interesting things
Kestrel Fox you say a pretty flutterby
yes this is a very Sunday sentiment that
I pretty flutterby
and there were some common or some
African jokers around here as well which
I can't see at the moment oh okay we're
going to get back to our Kenyan genus it
was managed to find I think is fifth or
sixth mammal of the day just look at
this and how things are just rolling and
I'm getting some red work red carpet
welcome in South Africa and look at the
alleys there when we found them
initially we saw they had a lot of mud
baths on their bodies but now or you can
see they're doing a dust bath so they're
getting a second coat of the sunscreen
from what they had just gotten a few
minutes ago
is it that beautiful
look at that if you look at them
carefully you can see the amount of Matt
yes yes they are rumbling there and if
you look at them carefully you can see
the got a lot of a mud the mud cover
which is very very wet sorry about that
just some nice guests also enjoying the
view like us and just look at that so
what should happen is cuz the first cut
oh they have of the mud is wet so the
dust will tend to stick and you know how
we build homes here in Africa will put
mud which marred and cover it with dry
excuse me excuse me just like that and
that one makes a very very good piss and
covers them very very nicely why don't
we get a little closer to them because
that's a great view and I'm getting
excited every other minute
having seen elephant this morning and
now what a blessing to see them again in
the afternoon eh
they were very busy eating this money
and this time with seeing on similar
moment joining them having adjustable
and that's why I've always said in my
life every day in the bush is a
different day every day is like reading
a new page on a book and look at that
see how deluxe they are
Hrothgar your question is did I find out
what could have been wrong with the
elephant we saw this morning I post that
question to my colleagues in the camp
and all of us are going to meet tonight
after dinner and try and explore and
find out what could be the possibilities
of those pink ears and why we saw a bit
of blood coming it from its anise will
definitely explore and yes giraffe cow
please be with us tomorrow again and
most likely we'll have an answer for you
how relaxed they are and you can tell if
you treat animals nicely they'll also
treat you the same way you don't get so
close to them you're not so loud scuse
me
thrashing you asking how do they keep
the dust or the dust out of the eyes if
you look at the elephant's carefully and
I'm sure Seb being such a wizard on
camera walk he'll bring us close to an
elephant I look at the very long
eyelashes you see on that one there look
at the very long eyelashes so what they
will do as they throw up or this plush
like that when exactly speak of the
devil they're just on their bodies they
very quickly close their eyes and the
eyelids will cover the eyes and of
course the long eyelashes will help in
making sure the dust doesn't get into
their eyes just like you you know how
when you walk and you know something is
coming try how you very quickly close
your eyes the elephant's also do the
same
isn't that amazing what a woman said
there mm-hmm
it's very exciting for me err absolutely
I agree with all of you that this is a
great sighting and you see the position
of your feet there as they keep picking
up the dust and doing a bit of scratch
there on the temporal ground
we've got impalas
snorting there and I'm not sure yes and
the elephants have says they also look
in the same direction and the baby their
eyes trying to nurse
and you you never know we'll see a
combination of that call from the
Ellie's I mean from the impalas and the
behavior of the Ellie's here they all
look in the same direction the nails
have just stopped teaching now he is out
on both of them it could have been a for
solemn and they seem like all is good in
the deciding to do the thing see that
young one there look at it look at it
look at that definitely definitely very
good very good that submitting to me
tells me there could be something in
this little block here and I'm sure we
will try and try and compete out and
find out what that could be because that
trumpeting was not variable this had an
elephant I think they are all related
but that something to me doesn't sound
very very normal just get so close and
find out what could be happening here
because that's a straw man and you
should behavior of Ellis they were not
trumpet for no reason we're not very far
from my favorite tea to a hot water hole
but that trumpeting leaves with a few
questions
hopefully the final destination of this
Ellis will be the [ __ ] to go for a
drink or possibly even a swim this is
very exciting for me say we standing up
to get the highest vantage point
Linda I couldn't agree with you Father
that you could watch elephants all day
for the big mammals this is my favorite
anymore as I said before by what did you
how they behave and they will be here at
all the Impala si are going crazy and it
could be a combination of writing for
the impalas it could be a combination of
any concern of a predator around here
but again you never know we got one huge
male coming down here I'm not sure he's
coming to say hello David and welcome to
South Africa if you decide to move here
David we shall give you enough
entertainment and you will forget East
Africa huge bull just walking so close
to us
very majestic
can hear him cracking and breaking the
sticks it's working
Craigie sorry about the poll there and
your question is have I ever seen
elephants innocent Craig or we had them
sneeze I'll be happy I can tell you I
haven't heard of that and if that should
happen I'll be one very happy boy but
that's a very interesting question Craig
bear hopefully today could be the day we
hear them sneeze who knows the zone is a
fast same for everything so the seams
have comes down now because initially
the trumpeting we had before to me was a
big concern and the impalas give some
alarm the ellie's did the same but now
things seem to have come down and it
could be a predator also that came very
quickly and took off and once the
reality is gone everything comes down
let it say that yeah the cheetah
waterhole is not very very far from here
and I'm crossing fingers hoping that
they might be getting there for a quick
drink and if that happens I can tell you
we'll be expecting to get better sure
and I do not know what James is doing
with trees the whole afternoon being a
Sunday can he tell us what he's doing
well I suspect you probably won't be
able to tell you what tell him what I am
doing because there's nothing secret
about it but this tree I told you the
other day was a rare tree on Juma and in
fact this tree isn't on juvenile it's
you know little secret it's just on
feyza i'm standing one foot off the road
but I figure they were in - looking at
their tree I'm pretty sure this is the
centered thorn and it's one of the most
common acacia trees or Virgilio trees
down on the river sort of side of the
sabi sands was gainful
and it's called the centered thorn
because if you break open the pod and
smell the SAP
it smells like those Apple sweets you
know if you have those apple flavored
boiled sweets oh and if you get them
where you happen to be in the world
that's what it smells like it's a
delicious smell but you are immediately
induced to do this sort of thing but
beyond measure
it is absolutely unspeakably better and
their tiny little drop has fooled my
whole mouth with a taste of a bile and
so the sweet gentle childhood nostalgic
smell of Apple boiled sweets all those
lollipops used to get his pops and
called he's ruined by the taste that's
why it's called the scented thorn or the
chillier nylock ticker and I showed you
one that had died the other day that
fallen over it been killed by elephants
I think and they're so few of them
they're a couple of quarantine keyrings
just outside the camp but otherwise
there really are not many down here up
at least up here down in the South quite
a few and certainly as you head down
towards kwazulu-natal there are many
many it came from anyway so no I will
just quickly sneak out
carrot cube I don't think even sugar
would make a difference - that tasted
really is very disgusting it leaves the
same aftertaste however it's quite
interesting as the bark the inner bark
of Knob form if you cut open a knob form
and slice out the inner bark and eat
that it's quite a nice kind of chewing
gum type thing as relatively sweet but
it doesn't it leaves the same aftertaste
as that very bitter bile tasting SAP
yuck party we're going to head back into
Juma we've given up on there any Lions
the Cossack Stefan didn't come back yet
so we're gonna head down to tree house
down and see what's going on there I
don't think anyone knows the answer to
this question Cherie the rarest tree in
the world I think probably has not been
described by science because nobody's
bothered to see it there are a number of
protected tree species in South Africa
the bio lab is one of them the jackal
berry is one of them but I think these
are protective trees because they sought
after for their wooden and for their and
their fruits and that sort of things the
human harvesting is causing a sort of
decline in their numbers but I don't
know what the rarest tree in the world
is I suspect like I say it's probably
some forest tree somewhere in the
jungles of the Congo or perhaps South
America or Southeast Asia that hasn't
been described yet I'd be happy to take
any feedback that you might have on that
school
here is not a particularly rare treat
that seem to be able to have a tree day
today I will try and find some mammals
this is of course the force marula tree
of some reason vm's favorite tree
Kevin why it shouldn't be so but this is
what it is then you can see once the
elephants have taken the bark off its
opened it up to borer beetles I think
that's no in fact that's definitely not
a boring beetle these little things here
are borer beetles you see the little
ones possibly even some carpenter bees
but what this is is a woodpecker
hammering a hole to pull out the larvae
of the insects that have laid their eggs
in the wood isn't that cool say it's
cool Craig it's very cool apparently ok
carry on its of life on that little tree
sitting as it is watching the Sunday
sunset David I would can see is now not
only finding the animals but correctly
predicting their movements which is most
impressive this is unbelievable for me
because what I ant anticipated is
happening and yes I agree with you
Cassie I guessed what could happen and
the chances were they were heading right
for my favorite waterhole chitwan
waterhole and look at them now online
I'll keep quiet for a few seconds for
you just to enjoy this view
this is for me magnificent
my anticipation has worked fine and my
guess was they might be coming to have a
drink and yes right they're having a
drink and we got the Egyptian geese next
to them and they're like you mind your
business you mind our business it's time
for us to drink
we know you live here but you also need
this water to quench our thirst look at
the big board is just walking in front
of us look at his size Debbie this is
also called a fiesta I agree with you
this is a fiesta true party here funny
that the drinking and same time doing
the number two business I don't
understand the behavior of that
particular young youngster looks like to
me is a boy and I would easily say boys
will be boys you come to drink in it
respect your water in holy service
laughing that was not very so that was
out of character yeah I mean Sarah
Grizzly you don't pee and you poop in
your nice watering hole if you're
getting some nice cold orange juice for
example and then you behave like that
it's not be very very good for the next
guest you notice how the big male stands
out he doesn't show any signs of being
in must so that's why you see the
females are very very comfortable with
him there in general sometimes when you
get the big bulls in must and when they
come close to the females you see the
females reacting angrily and not getting
very happy with a militant must
see this is a very young baby there if
you look absolutely absolutely this is
magnificent as I said look at that young
baby they're trying to catch up with
mama teeny teeny teeny Oh Tay is still
under 1 year young young young young
great stuff yeah and he maybe takes very
very good cover from everybody and you
see how clever they eleazar they keep
their right in the middle of the hard
there and maybe the mother will drink
enough for herself and also for the baby
just see how the drops well done good
camera work there Seb just look at the
drops how they fall back right in the
water and look at that and it's the
water or the drop bounce right from the
surface of the water
see that well done good camera except
there so the scoop as much as you know
as much what is possible for them to
quantity a fast here and you can see
that has like ha an eyelash or someone
was doing some beauty work on her face
the young one there but that's a little
line of dust that wasn't covered very
well by the mud it's like someone was
trying to do an eye brown the wrong side
thirsty thirsty alleys
they may not seem to be drinking a lot
they I was trying to go in and you can
see the legs up to the knees you know oh
the whole trunk was in the world if you
look carefully which was a thing first
attempt to go in the water and oops
come on the mud check there I guess the
big one days the magic in general the
oldest he's always the mature he is
trying to put some order in the heart
here and we're waiting for her to give
the command
uncle Ian would like to know what sorry
crusty fumbling you'd like to know if
elephants could get an infection from
drinking dirty water I'll tell that one
I do not know but I would say in the
wilderness where we are it's very very
difficult to get any dirty water I
wouldn't know if there's no outside
human interference in the wilderness
everything tends to remain clean unless
for example outsi is some dangerous sea
or poisonous snake who died in the water
or the solid by mistake
I highly doubt that should happen but
they could very good mechanism to take
care of or don't eat and I mean what
they drink I would highly doubt don't
get an infection and if that should
happen I think mother nature depending
on what they eat would take care of that
very very quickly a few more aliens have
just come in and they might go back to
the water to have more drinks I'm just
loving this
so I think a decision has to be made
there I think there's an agreement and
they are discussing something you can
see the change in the body language
there how many have had enough drink
how many have not we need to do this I'm
just guessing I wouldn't know what
they're talking about but definitely you
can tell there's some important
discussion going on there we're just
very quiet wait and see what they agree
to do
only you'd like to know if there's a
difference between the South African and
the Kenyan elephant I would say no
everything behavior reproduction habitat
habits everything remains the same gas
station period like you know what I
might have picked up and I'm still
trying to talk with my presenters or my
colleagues here in South Africa
I thought the alleys or the elephants in
South Africa a little bit rounded as
compared to the elephants in Kenya I'm
thinking so I'm yet to see more house of
elephants my second hand luckily today
my second had a very fun to see
I'm here to see more and look at them
closely but I would be happy to know if
the same but I think this ones here are
more rounded than the ones we have in
Kenya which I think they are more
angular
well it's time to move and you can see
the big one there's the magic one has
changed the direction I was walking the
other way and the magic was I said this
is the direction you're going we are all
going south mover great wat hallelujah
and as the elephants are living cept you
see the smaller crop may be broken over
there
right now we're changing from the Mamas
and we got our tail water activity what
a great spot to be at this water hauler
and the croc doesn't seem to be worried
and Steve have a different type of
mammal mmm a mammal that likes water
almost as much as elephants do for water
back and we are sitting here with a male
who is licking his lips for unknown
reasons
he's just been standing there staring
into the distance not eating not
ruminating just the odd lick of the lips
from time to time and we are on our way
to tree how two twin dams we have just
visited two treehouse dam waterhole and
no animals moving in and around and the
temperatures slowly starting to to
subside so we hoping at any one stage
now we might get the movement of some
spotted a feline of sorts but this water
buck is very relaxed don't know what's
going on with him maybe he's hoping his
ladies are going to be returning soon
and she just loved that nose and so wet
what's he doing Dave do you know man
it's just thinking just thinking
he's enjoying a Sunday afternoon cursed
you're right what did you hear boy
the beautiful horns that white ring on
the bottom David would be familiar with
this one but then also that a faster
water buck that has got the entire white
circle
not just the ring and there we go now we
get the other profile is like this is my
better side
let's go dabs quickly great we just so
100 just come in just listen to that
[Applause]
I'm not sure what could have gone wrong
because the pastor of Aires had their
jump drink and all full and they were
ready to leave and - all right another
hand of about eight ten was coming in in
the heart that was living with a very
quick u-turn and came back towards these
other ones and there was a little
confrontation not very big between the
two hearts I think now what they're
doing is trying to know each other and
dream meet and greet as the hippo is
wondering what could have gone wrong
I think the one had that had finished
drinking now
is making a move they won the heart
behind them has not had a drink not even
had dropped so there could be two
definitely different families that met
and I'm not sure how I do not want to
meet and it's a huge bull following them
there and you can tell a hundred and
fifty percent that's a boy now this
could be a bit of a concern
Deb yes those sounds of Ellie's
trumpeting there was great the aquatic
awesome you know echo tones or natural
tones of the earth or of the wilderness
how majestic when you see them walking
there on the edge of the waterhole great
lighting and almost you meant not even
hear them walk as much as they look so
huge and behind them the male is
following them very very closely I'm not
sure this milk could be in must and
that's why the Elly's got very
uncomfortable and they're going away
from him I'm still convinced the second
hand of elephants the second I might
come for a drink because they didn't
drink any water as soon as the other
heart turn around and they came to meet
them and there was a little bit of a
scuffle there four-wheel drive to get
over large to keep going go good girl
yes and that's another boy their
youngsters in this heart
very very good light coming through
there after leaving the waterhole I
still believe the second heart of
elephants will turn around and come for
a drink I mean they eat so much
elephants they also need to drink
equally as much Amelia your question is
do all families have a magic yes
all families will have a magic and she's
a female who makes the most crucial or
the most important decisions however a
family might be be it of two or three
members or two about 50 members it's
always one family that will always be a
magic Emilia in every family of the
elephants
it doesn't have to be necessarily the
largest but in general is always the
oldest the oldest definitely will have
had lots of experience in life insurance
making good calls and good judgments
when they'll be you know any any
concerns or any doubt in the harder but
also you tend to see in general also the
mass trucks are big in size that only
still enjoy the green grass cause is
pretty fresh and it gets very soft being
near the water hole hopefully doesn't
lag behind so much and it's left by the
others the things very slowly they one
had a dent or hadn't had a drink at the
very end of the water hole is thinking
of getting in the water now to have a
drink - I think it's their time the
disagreement that was there might have
been sorted amicably now and elephants
mostly always very closely related
Andrea you'd like to know why is so many
elephants in Kenya don't have tears or
their tails are missing we have been
having this debate for quite some time
and we all of us have different theories
of why these tears are missing and one
of the theories that have personally had
is genetical and you know that happens
if the mother or the father didn't have
a tail that might happen to the calf too
we have got when they're playing or when
they're being playful sometimes you see
them either grubbing the tails when
they're young with your trunks and when
one tried to flee the tail we just snap
we have seen some bloody Alize when
they're young and the tails look in
bloody and quantities are missing and we
have said chances are that is what could
have happened at that theory that
doesn't carry so much water to me is
occasionally maybe and maybe when
they're very young predators like lions
have gone for the babies when the
mothers are not very very watchful and I
mean I mean we have those three theories
in Kenya but hopefully some of the
experts will tell us for a fact what
could have you know happen to these
Ellis's missing tails in a part for
missing tails their life has continued
as normal
I haven't seen one elephant missing
after a while haven't seen many this is
my second heart of elephants to see and
from what I saw in the morning and all
what I've seen here all their tails
intact and in place
I'm still looking for the LED so this
model the pink here's we haven't seen it
see could definitely be in a different
hard
James is working towards another
waterhole I am walking towards another
waterhole I'll here we go come on David
at least one Craig what we have here is
Poli rankest the Aunt Polly Rinka
species and what I'm going to do is use
this as a sig taken to a story about
ants that milk Athens and we had a long
discussion the other day about the drop
tail dance that were milking aphids on a
grass stalk and I originally made the
mistake of saying well they're obviously
hunting the aphids and then somebody
very kindly pointed out that that was
nonsense and they're much more likely
milking the efforts for their honeydew
which is the sort of excretion they
produce when they eat when they drink
the plants SAP I agreed with that and
then said that there was quite a nice
little arrangement you know it wasn't
very harmful well quick as a flash
Judy H found me a wonderful article of
research that shows that those ends that
milk aphids are not being very nice to
them at all quite often they secrete
chemicals that result in the aphids
being unable to move properly and so
they become more dose are much more easy
to milk sometimes I think they give them
chemicals that might actually kill them
they give them chemicals that stop this
maybe induce them to breed or something
like that basically they control them
and get them into a big group together
with chemicals and all of that exude by
these aphids milking ants wonderful
Polly Reyes is not an aphid and Luca I'm
not actually sure what Piraeus eats
there
what you eat my dear
Sunday roast for you we have a Sunday
roast waiting for us the excited Craig
sherry he says very good
I felt like before we found that ant
litter basically we just be walking
today we haven't found anything of
massive its significance yet and we're
hoping that that will take place as
treehouse dam which is where we're
hitting now it's not too far from here
it's quite far from there up to font
yeah maybe we'll bump into something
like that buffalo bull or perhaps
another elephants see what we've got
over here on this dense tree was that
sarcastic point one own elephant will be
nice yes I agree with you I agree
militant will be very nice I'm told
everybody that it's so relaxed here on
Sundays you know the two ladies in the
final control eating cheesecake as we
speak
suddenly feel quite hungry now what I
was hoping to find here is perhaps
something under the bark okay yes
what we do have here and I want to
destroy too much of it is the track
and detritus of a wood termite you see
that Craig see if I can wedge it off
watch out they're doing particularly
poor job try some mistake gonna work
it's not gonna work anyway
what's happened here is that the of the
here we go the wood termites have come
up here and they're long gone from here
now they've eaten off what they wanted
to eat and they have basically lift the
old bark intact and they've just gone
for the underside of the wood
now the reason they've done that is so
that they as they were working here as
they were taking the wood that they
wanted from this tree they could do it
in complete protection so there would
have been completely underneath the
surface of this dead tree I think it was
probably it was a nob thorn it's got a
big tree at one stage maybe a very very
old dead red bush willows but they were
completely protected from the Sun and
from any predators except perhaps
very-very woodpeckers are trying to get
through the wood and now you can see
they've moved on and of course as I've
told you before this sand is apparently
edible yeah never understood that
I just don't get it David finds another
mammal James will always eat anything
how he has been surviving all these
years in the wilderness
I do not know there's nothing he doesn't
try and right we are those two hippos
they're Irish were the plane oh they are
meeting and after a great show we had
with Ellis
now we have the hippos here and telling
us this particular to either the two
youngsters being very very playful and
I'm sure the parents are watching
he turning around enjoying the cold
temperatures of the water
yeah the Smallville play I did it very
closely later all the very good friends
when they get big and older you'll see
them having very big teeth marks on
their bodies and that's because of the
huge toss whoo good stuff is your tip of
the other one we're just walking exactly
I can see the pink under the neck all
right sit down again that has a hold of
something on the left
oh is that the men that could have been
that tooth schmuck I don't know
yeah I do not know what ravine but tan
yeah it looks like the skin has a little
in the wound Oh little tumor I don't
know what it is it reminds of me of the
giraffe that we saw earlier that had
that big scar on the neck but these
things alone has happened out here in
the wild wilderness you know they the
animals will fight more males than
females and scars be they claw marks
teeth marks are left on the bodies most
will survive some unfortunately will die
this morning I had a question from one
of the viewers who wanted to know if you
know he was asleep in water and I might
have given answer that was not very sure
of but I've done my research and found
out yes hippos would comfortably sleep
in water
how do you directional if elephants and
hippos would have a confrontation or
would have an issue or a concern or go
for each other hole in the water solve
them or really that happens elephants
will come to the watering hole for very
short time countering unless they won't
have a swim but if that happens they're
so huge to the hippos and the hippos may
move a little bit away from them but in
general we haven't seen them fighting
and elephants that big hippos of that
big and full of apparently herbivores
and they have a commonality on what they
eat
so hippos will not go for the elephants
and elephant oh really
oh they go for the hippo the respect
each other just like how we see the
hippos and the Crocs like the one small
clockwise in the water
respecting each other in such a
beautiful habitat and as soon as you so
before the elephant's did the drinking
they just took off and they were done
and is a clearer understanding we can
with drink we're done we're gone is that
simple so listen to that
I do not know what story they're telling
and I'm sure either tale tells the
communicating and passing some good
stories to them the temperatures coming
down and as the ghosty dusk is when he
pause will always leave the water and
most likely they are making plans of
where they'll go and grace tonight and
one of the regions that makes it easier
for the hippos to sleep under the water
if you look at them carefully there you
can see is like the nose and the eyes
are on top of the head like other
animals you got the eyes for example you
know on the side of the head the hippos
it's like the eyes are right on top and
the nose too so one day however you
don't up under the waters here for about
five minutes before they come out to
breathe they could come from a stain and
just pop up of a quick carbon dioxide
out oxygen in and rush back in the water
can see you'd like to know how a hippo's
make such a loud noise a number of
reasons and it's basically
communicational number one and as i said
earlier they could be making plans of
what happens tonight once they are out
and they go foraging or they go feeling
but it shouldn't be one call from one
particular say dominant male he would be
making a territory call and it would be
passing a message you know what yep I am
in charge here and I am the boss that
out say the two reasons they make those
calls
and ideally they would be communicating
with each other like how human beings
you know will always pass messages to
each other
Loree you would like to know if the
hippos make plans to stay together on
the out of water and I would say yes we
have always said here in the wilderness
safety in numbers
occasionally you might see one lagging
behind on one going off from the others
and that becomes a bit tricky because he
or she might get lost or you know get
brought down by the Predators in general
they'll always stay together and that
way again safety numbers go for it eat
together and come back to the water
you know adorned together
this is beautiful stuff and Steve is
still on the driver David is stealing
the show this afternoon and it should
ruins the day it seems but never fear we
were busy looking here at a crested
Franklin but you can't see him anymore
because he's too camouflaged so we're
gonna continue on we've found some
tracks of what I'm assuming is husana we
decided to come onto that road called
mumble loop let me show you cuz and I
sometimes these road names can be a bit
confusing you just switch off the engine
there okay so we are a new row that's
been formed off of number that goes
along this drainage system here and pops
up I was fortunate about two three weeks
ago to get her sauna and a pan just down
here and Dave now having a chat about it
and we got some tracks coming in onto
the loop and nons driven here this
morning so maybe baby lucky the little
chief you know he likes to just show
himself up when when things are quiet
the chief comes out just like that
little chief of sauna two year and about
three month old leopards he's a very
good friend of mine very very good
friend and obviously with David's doing
all the hard work in finding all the
animals that side it's left us time to
drive and drive and drive and Herbie is
now calling me
Herbies tell you about what a lovely
gentleman who he is
yeah I think I think it's for solace
afonso I'm on mumble OOP I just headed
east at the moment Jodi's on the other
side he's quite far away he obviously
heard me telling you all that we've
probably got tracks of a sauna
last time I spotted him was right about
this little pan and then we lost him as
he disappeared through there so this
little pan is a little bit drier than I
expected it to be but we're going to
have a little scratch around well that's
why elephants have been in and they have
smashed it not only do warthogs
like to wallow in the mud the elephants
like to come through and to cover
themselves in it and then carry the mud
away
these areas will get deeper and deeper
you can actually see all along the
ground here the splatter of how the
elephants would have thrown the mud over
their head
just make it out there that's mud
splatter no other animal does that with
the mud you might see chunks of it as
the animal moves off but elephants been
throwing this over their head and to
their back and forth and quite often you
can actually see the fortrex away a male
or whatever stood all the matters
falling down and then we stands where
it's clean underneath but we are now in
the West hopefully we'll find something
out yet but it is a marvelous afternoon
and barring that we'll hit up to before
Sudan for a sunset shot and let's go
over to James and see whereabouts on the
reserve year's slender oh I am on
Rebecca's Road everybody which is the
Central Road and rumor and I found some
termites very different from the ones we
had before they are of course the
harvested termite and they are blessed
with the well the pigment of melanin in
their skins which of course allows them
to work in the day in the hot African
Sun unlike most the other termites which
must operate at night
interestingly I don't know where their
home is and I have nasty suspicion I've
sat on it you see how they've gone
completely still and that's because
there are no something's up they know
that they've been spotted normally you
can see exactly where they're dragging
the stuff to if I haven't destroyed
their home no I haven't I'm sure it's up
here somewhere and you'll find the
entrance is covered in little sticks I
think these guys must be very brave
outliers
we've moved quite far anyway it'll be in
here somewhere
they don't grow mounds and build mods
nothing grows mod that is the harvester
termite all right here we carry on here
maybe fruitless search for anything with
a heartbeat here continues child of the
universe our evidence today would
suggest yes that that is exactly the
case that a Kenyan guides are better at
finding large animals than South African
ones to South Africans have managed to
find between them
I think the mammal count is one water
buck that Stephen found and the Kenyan
guide his most wild elephants in
hippopotamus kudu niala I think he had
some in part at one stage warthog six or
seven species of mammal so obviously yes
Kenyans are better at this than South
Africans and the giraffe yes sorry about
that
at least we have a Kenyan guide with us
who's able to help us oh we did have an
Impala Thank You Herbert you have found
they're not as good
however at finding hoverflies we are the
best at finding hoverflies
and I know that's why most of you are
watching this show it's not for giraffe
and elephant
leopards and lions much more so it is
for the humble hoverfly of a Sunday
afternoon now you can tell this is a fly
Craig do you know how you tell it's a
fly not be Craig's is which means no I
have no idea please would you explain it
to me so yes I shall it has got two
wings only whereas a B Craig would have
one what sir
yes exactly four wings two hind and two
four got a nice little proboscis on it
but I don't think is used for anything
other than trying to get into the
nectaries of flowers and sucking the
next out of those flowers and it's
called a hover fly because I'm gonna ask
you one more question Craig because it
can't no hover you almost right there I
mean you chose from you took a 50-50
chance and this half hovering hover fly
is able to very accurately place itself
in the air like a hummingbird I can
miniature hummingbird it's able to place
itself accurately in the air and get the
nectar ease of my new little flowers so
that's what that is then we're not only
are we good at filing hover flies we're
also good at finding a fits here a whole
lot of aphids and it seems to be a food
season at the moment and in fact I think
I've just realized what it is that the
gummy grass has it's gum for I will try
and find some gummy grass for you to
explain there but little gummy patches
here on the nodes and I think that stops
the aphids from getting up to the
inflorescences and damaging them so
that's what's going on there you see
them all that crud if it's a my new
favorite subject I better learn
something about them
so there you are no big animals but well
vastly vast array of diversity here
customers go again for that question
from cheeky geeky bits as far as I heard
it it was how many insects will glow in
the dark if I black light shines on them
I don't know
Oh Rocky UV light okay I didn't even
know what a black light is and you don't
mess you must mean the UV light do well
if if it's a UV light then I am going to
say probably very few insects but of
course all the scorpions will shine
under the influence shine green under a
UV light I don't know of any insects
that will I feel like there might be
some though I don't know of any cheeky
geeky bit but it's possible there are
some all the scorpions will shine under
the influence of UV lunch however which
I've said before and that's to cover
over the fact that I don't know if there
are any insects that don't that do but I
was also just having a little reader
game about the heat glow worms and their
ability to produce of course cold light
which science has yet to replicate
apparently okay let's go back to the guy
who can find animals I'm told that's
where we gain by Kirsten
it has been sheer luck today and I think
I put down my diary as one of my biggest
days the highlights of her develop on
this morning the giraffe that we just
saw and that excitement by that watering
hole of chitwa of all those Ellie's
drinking and all what was happening
around that area for the like half an
hour so we've been there that is big one
for me and in Kenya's who will see Alice
will see elephants but I think that was
rather special moment for me to have
seen the blood close and very relaxed
the small you know confrontation we saw
between the two different hearts and
that was a nice nice nice moment the
temperatures have now considerably gone
down and you can see every what a second
layer but nothing is that said but
nothing compared to this morning this
morning was what I would say who Lala it
was very very cold and serviced laughing
they are gonna see who Lala but again it
was much cooler now than when we started
the Safari much earlier so we left our
watering hole or my watering hole for
now let me call it that way hopefully
the full control agree I call it my
watering hole as long as I be here and
heading out in a different direction now
something maybe on my first sported
little part that will claim to be mine
James it's not tired of insects today
being a Sunday nothing is being a Sunday
it's got to do with the fact that I
can't find anything else in fact I
didn't even find this one Herbert did
that for us this is a pirate fly
everybody and a pirate fly is an eater
of ants normally and also I'm told
reliably I Herbert it is parasitized by
the cordyceps fungus now for those of
you don't know what the cordyceps fungus
is it is of course an Indo parasitoid
and found many on insects and other
arthropods thus are there thus in Tomoe
pathogen - a genic fungi I'm obviously
reading that right now as opposed to
well remembering it but basically what
it will do is eventually explode out off
the fly and rendering it update of
course it'll come out in these kind of
you'll see the my celia coming out of
the fly and these spores will be cast to
the wind and then picked up by another
capitalist pirate fly hopefully not that
one like Captain Jack now I think
they're probably sitting on these grass
stalks waiting for flies not flies ants
possibly even the drop tailed ants and
they've chosen a very specific species
to sit on they're sitting largely on
this die hit troponin contour ters will
spear grass see over here Greg here is a
gathering of the die hedgehog and
contort us and that's what it looks like
once it's shed all of its seeds
beastly fly it's look like a really
nasty fare there yes Cathy does a little
bit like a house fly eat I convinced her
but some identification yeah I will
clarify with him he's walked off now but
I think it could easily be a pirate fly
they would explain why it's sitting here
looking for things good where our insect
Sunday continues there's a sir meander
all from this direction here we've got
about half an hour left of light to find
something Kirsten has told us we may not
come home until we have found something
large with a heartbeat I have told the
story of my hats to see Indian is really
not them my fault that I have a hat that
looks like this I have ordered another
one by the way is another hat is on its
way to help me you say do I have a pair
of tattered shorts and shirt to go with
my hat
no Cecilia I don't as you can see my
shirt is not to tattered it's looking a
little bit ropey but it's not quite
finished just yet the reason my hat is
like this is because I very kindly
donated my hat to Ralph
okay that's why it looks like this it is
a function of my extreme magnanimity the
dire have sacrificed my looks for Ralph
and I I feel that you're all teasing me
about it and I don't think it's
warranted I then think that's very nice
of you especially on Sunday Jerry says
if I could just cut that thread well
Jerry I'll pull it off for you okay
happy now
come on Craig no one appreciates us or
our flies or our hymen not trees or
anything else that we find here let's go
to Steve who's found something that
anybody could find anybody could find
indeed well the Sun rises and sets every
single day that's the one thing we know
for sure and we are on the western side
on that very nice road called
drakensberg and we are looking to the
west and the Sun the golden orb that
creates all of life is slowly setting in
the distance we can at least contribute
something to this drive and a sunset is
always an important part so I'm just
going to give you a few moments to enjoy
that with us
for you birds calling in the distance
sometimes there's no need to label
anyone just a beauty the nature the
stillness
ever thought for all those animals that
are about to be shrouded in darkness
where all the predators come out to play
do you think if we lived out here
without any shelter but any sort of
defense just in the middle of nowhere do
you think we would appreciate the sunset
every day like we do at the moment
imagine what we think of the sunrise
we'd be so excited about that we're
doubly excited about the sunrise with
the light shows itself in the setting of
the Sun would Herald some craziness
just soaking it all up another day in
the African savannah what did all of you
do with your day did you make the most
of it that's all the life we have is
just the rising and setting of Suns how
many of them in our life do we have our
meat sauces to eat achieve we appreciate
what we have
cat uh no it's very hard to to get bored
looking at the sunset and there's not a
cloud in the sky which actually detracts
a little bit from the beauty of these
skies you know I mean what I love about
the the sunsets here is there's so many
different types and elements and
moisture quality in the air and
pollution elements of dust everyone is
different everyone is unique you can
take thousands of pictures and not a
single one will be the same even if you
took it from the exact same spot it'll
always be different so you never get
bored of the Sun and what I love about
it is that that is real that's happening
right now in the moment there's no
thought of anything else but what I like
to always reflect on with the sunset is
that did we achieve in the day what we
set out to achieve and if not why
and then hopefully the next day we can
better ourselves the human race we need
to better ourselves every single day as
we go and the setting and rising the Sun
is that clock to the end of our lives
and we need to pay attention to that
that we're going to soldier on we are in
the usual haunt for tündi we didn't
materialize anything with those tracks
of a Sun it's possible that they were
from last night where he had come down
and brands had found him down sort of
close to twin dams it's kind of an area
he seems to move in so we didn't see him
I didn't find anything fresher than what
I'd seen but who knows what might pop
out now it is cooling drastically almost
gonna be time to put on a jacket
and those of you who who do watch the
show quite regularly will remember that
undie had a kill just over here last
week last week Sunday last week Saturday
it'll Steinbach kill was marvelous I got
stuck in a hole just in there I'll never
forget that it was a big hole
I remember when James came to help me he
just went good gosh my whole vehicle had
pretty much fallen into the ground it
was so fantastic because I think I'd
been live and I'd said if I do disappear
and fall down a hole I do apologize and
then we went off there and then I fell
down a hole so I'm glad that didn't
happen live because I would have looked
quite frightening on their camera the
entire the entire vehicle just did this
but Tristan Dix if you're watching I did
not fall out the car he still he still
gets very upset when we talk about that
video even though he'll watch it and
show it to people so the views keep
going up people like I really don't like
this video of me falling out the car and
he shows it to people and then someone's
like what video this one he shows
another person so I just love how well
edited that was he was giving Taylor
mccurdy a whole lot of whole lot of
grief about falling into falling in the
mud and then as he well lit the way the
Edit had made it look really good in
there whoops well he went the side I
love that
can you say that again which animal is
the most free what it is friendliest
Samad cheetah a very sort of adaptable
animal and she to get very relaxed to
people now they don't see us as food and
they're not threatened by us once they
have but you added to cheetah that is
sort of a very very wild sheets will run
away from people from a distance but
they do relax quite quickly to people
and they can be quite friendly squirrels
can be extremely friendly if you raise
them from from babies as well as
mongooses if you can deal with their
enormous amount of energy they just do
not stop digging and licking and
grooming they will drive you absolutely
mad giraffe not because we've had
reports of a person being killed by
giraffe recently but that was more of a
different incident I suppose it wasn't
wild wild wild but you never get close
to a Wilder off you'd always move away
thinking I mean y'all have become quite
a [ __ ] wait so they get very used to
living in camps and living around people
but you never be able to go and touch at
those so none of these animals are
unless you read them from youngster asks
is something you can walk up sing go
hello and I'm all let me touch you no it
doesn't work like that but they lose a
lot of them don't have a fear of us if
they get used to you and they can get
quite sort of obituaries and I wouldn't
say friendly in the manner that they
make you tea or come over with scones or
anything like that but they will
definitely get quite used to and stay
close by but an animal that I've seen
many times in life yeah well there's a
tortoise that comes into camp but he's
got or she if there's a she and it's
named Gregory it's a very interesting
story what goes on where we live and she
comes in all the time to come and get
food and you know the girls are very
friendly towards Gregory and they're
constantly feeding her little bits of
offcuts of spinach and whatever they
might find in the fridge and she's the
friendliest tortoise I've ever seen but
then there is an ulterior motive
so you know while animals
you could never really call them
friendly like azan seeing people that
have had the habitual to dwarves they
come really close into camp but they're
very powerful animals are very dangerous
tasks and if that animal decides one day
just to give you a bit of a bit of a
bump it's going to hurt and could
potentially kill you especially if the
if it cuts you on the leg on a femoral
artery or something so I no means should
anyone try and habituate animals to the
point where you can touch them all the
time that I don't think is is hundred
percent needed out here but you know
people do take in often animals and they
will become quite sort of accustomed I
know that close to its prey there's
Jessica the hippo that is a world-famous
hippo that people come and visit and she
sleeps inside on a bed and I'm afraid of
hippos that just takes one bite to cut
me in half so you don't want to have a
disagreement with that friendly animal
because you will lose but each to their
own
but squirrels can be very nice they're
quite a fun little animal but you've got
to get them from little pups little
babies bush babies I've seen people with
Bush babies but the problem Bush babies
is they like to urinate everywhere so if
you like being urinated on constantly
get yourself a bush baby
if you can't have against that then I
wouldn't advise getting a bush baby the
club in your hair and just start
urinating down your back if you're into
that sort of thing
go ahead lady I used to work with Sam
told me she had a bush baby that used to
do that and she liked it but I think
took a bit of getting used to
there's a different kind of shampoo bush
baby but essentially what the bush baby
is doing is marking use their territory
because they like to urinate and walk
around you none of their hands and they
walk around and everything that touches
that's my territory so in their club I
knew and then urinates that they're
basically owning you that's what they're
saying without saying anything so if you
like that kind of friendly go for it
ah just I love this time of year as the
weather changes than the air just as a
different flavor to the air and talking
about friendly things let's go over the
James Henry I'm so friendly
I will happen to show you his rust bush
winner which as Steve showed you earlier
today but I bet he didn't get quite as
close as Craig is getting wonderful I
told the they just said you can make tea
out of these pods I have tried it's
really very average too disgusting and
that is the russet bush woodland we are
on our way home now it has become quite
dark on account of the Setting Sun and
so we're just marching fairly quickly up
towards Kemp along in the twin dams Road
now there is an interesting tree here
Muldoon I have not managed to find
another insect I'm afraid we'd have been
looking though I promise what we might
find here on this tree which is known as
Ross Quincy I is of course the flea
beetle Andros Quincy I is identified by
the fact that it has spines and a
three-pronged leaf and Richard I believe
you've been asking about flea beetles
well this is the tree that they occur on
you can see that this trifoliate leaf
here that is the indicator of a ruse or
current tree not country raisin remember
the earthly the common names and also
these spines now the difference between
a spine and the thorn is that a spine is
a modified branch so if you look at this
one here you can see that it's got
leaves growing out of it but it is
obviously very sharp at the end and as
the spine becomes a more mature branch
it loses its sharpened edge and puts out
other spines from it and that of course
is distinct from a faun a thorn which
grows independently as a defensive
mechanism out of the plant and players
no further role in providing nutrition
or other leaves to the plant no that is
spined Roose Quincy I'm other plants
that have spines like that of course
include the green thorn or the Ballon
artis Megami the Torchwood
the decreased Eckerson area or sickle
Bush as it's called now those are the
main ones that have spines and not forms
I'm getting so desperate now that I
think I may even what I've got
zhuzi force well spotted there Craig
that's got thorns and not spines very
good you can see here that the thorns
play no role in sort of putting forth
shoots they are just there for defense
little enjoying his Sunday evening once
I point out something here
book book you say I look a bit lost and
I say I feel a bit discombobulated given
the distance we walked in the lack of it
content we've actually found I did see
something in here oh yes this is what I
want to talk about I want to talk about
this die hid repose and contort us we
have to do this one see everybody I know
all if most of you have seen this before
but I shall do it for those the benefit
of those who have not here we have the
alms of die hetra pogrom con tortoise
you see that craig never wallow and of
course now we do the magic trick you're
making him wet i dab oneself in the
parrot
your customer does not test though
cheesecake and if you watch it carefully
come on it's not doing it hang on let me
try that again
until it starts spinning that's what
they do is when they get wet they drill
themselves into the ground
returning no any non turning die Hitler
Potemkin tortoise this is a fantastic
magic trick as Kirsten says the seat is
right on the end there and the own will
kind of drill into the ground and the
seed will then germinate
I've always been very good at magic as
you can see I'm very good contracts I
have two fantastic contracts we're going
to make our way home as the Sun has gone
now let's see if David can find himself
a nocturnal animal rights I mean James
with seeds James with fruit James should
grass I'm not sure what James doesn't
eat but my advice to him is he should
eat a lot or he gets eaten but I'm happy
to hear he has started making his steps
home good boy
I am still absorbing my excitement from
those Ellie's earlier and I still can't
believe it
I'm still staying and asking Seb was
that real and like yes and you'll see
more and Josh was quite quite a show
going to show we'll see elephants in
Kenya and maybe not that close and not
as dramatic especially when we had those
two hearts meeting together and having a
little scuffle that was something that
was like what could be happening here
just slowly coming to a dumb Oh to
waterhole ragga we were a few days ago
and we had seen some big Buffalo male
laying around and I don't see there's
anybody home at the moment and what
should happen sometimes
if the animals are not fast enough or
they have had a lot of foliage of food
with most tenets in the middle count for
drink but very good deflection of the
trees they're in the water
good job sab you can hear the silence
now excellent that's like an upside down
tree I agree with you Carson that's
really beautiful really very beautiful
as the light is fading out slowly the
beauty does not stop in the wilderness
these are two trees and very good camera
work there by Sebastian mm-hmm and you
see the water weaves
making it even more colorful as they
move they're quite a popular waterhole
here when you'll get the animals coming
for a drink and be they either predators
or hobby boss and this one day look at
the light there as the Sun is fitting
out all the golden light excellent good
job still giving us that good view of
Juma and Steve got a feathered friend
my favorite kind of friends the
feathered kind and here we have got a
giant or ever Rose your owl and we are
obviously still in color and if you look
very carefully ladies and gentlemen
you'll notice that the eyelids are pink
which is the most bizarre thing I don't
know why a bird that is so camouflaged
has got pink eyelids isn't that a
gorgeous bird so regal
look so sort of majestically intelligent
not sure if you can hear the starlings
all around him going absolutely nuts few
birds a forked l-drago there's another
one of the shrikes the white crested
helmet rack they've all spotted him they
all wanted to go away that's what
happens with the silent hunters same as
the lipids once they get spotted near
alarm calls the rise that generally move
away because their ability to to be
stealthy disappears looking at that trap
again come on come a bit closer these
are creatures of the night Oh Roxy your
favorite bird fantastic I wonder if this
is a new bird for any of the viewers out
there yep you know if it is see those
pink eyelids and that very round face
ear tufts that you see are not actually
ears they are just Tufts that accent
camouflage a little bit of a toilet
break the ears actually on the side of
the head at different levels and the
sound comes into the face to that facial
disk and runs off the face at different
speeds to the ears on the side of the
head which are a different sort of
hemispheres on the side of the head and
they can hunt in pure darkness with
sound triangulating the movement of an
animal on the ground
look at those eyelids fantastic I saw
one of these taking off the other day
just after the show ended with the scrub
here perched in its talons and it was a
small scrubby but definitely had a very
painful or quick death if you can see
those marvelously powerful claws
attached to the branch they're beautiful
we go again folks
draaga is giving him a little bit of a
hard time just waking up missus Lapwing
the meals for these things can be
anything from scrub hairs to small birds
to rodents primarily they hunt things
moving around on the ground
not much of a raiding specialist but
they are opportunistic and they're also
very sort of predatory on other owls
this is the biggest hour we get in the
area
and they will chase a smaller owls and
kill them if they can because it's all
competition this is the largest owl I
said we find here and they have
separated their niche from the daytime
Raptors such as the tawny eagle possibly
even the martial Eagle maybe the
Marshalls a bit big but their food
resource is quite a similar one but
these guys hunt by night rather than by
day and that separates them in time what
have you spotted fantastic Karen if you
didn't get the name it is a giant eagle
owl or Averroes eagle owl and it is - we
get two of the largest owls in the
Savannah one is the PALS fishing owl
which is very closely associated with
water and permanent rivers and then you
get this one which is the more common
throughout the low felt and the most
sort of aggressive towards other Epps's
of the night and to even take a Franklin
that you can hear shouting there they've
probably spotted it as well and they're
not happy
alarm calls often bring all the birds
together
they've spotted the predator and it's
best to be alert and shouted at so that
it doesn't attack you because generally
predators don't attack things that are
aware of them because it's difficult
they want to save as much energy as
possible and be that stealthy silent
anta NOTAMs and age seven why does he
turn the head around while an owl can
almost turn its head all the way around
from left to right it enables them to
sit in one spot and be able to scan the
vegetation in every direction without
having to move they are extremely
camouflaged and if they move their body
they can give away their position a
little bit so by being able to just
rotate your head very easily it's almost
like having eyes in the back of the head
owls are quite sort of specialized in
that and it's part of their hunting
strategy and as they move their head you
can see how he's kind of moving his head
now is picking up some sound on the
ground there and by moving the head it
changes the frequency in the direction
that the sound is coming in on the
facial disk and then it allows it to
sort of pinpoint through sound not
through sight something rustling around
in the undergrowth peach man how many
owls species to be found in South Africa
well vis the Burroughs eagle owl is the
Pels oh sorry are these ours only found
in South Africa um well they're in
Africa I don't know how far north they
extend I can have a quick look
probably southern sub-saharan Africa
quite common but I don't think you find
them elsewhere in the world you don't
get too many species that cross
continents with regards to owls that I
know of not like the barn owl I think
the barn owl is quite a sort of a
European and an African owl but I've
never heard of the giant eagle ah
elsewhere beach man you can hear the
folks health drongo shouting some hippo
in the distance we're not far from
bubbles look damn now okay so it doesn't
say too much but it's all over South
Africa not in sort of the Cape region
but all over South Africa and I'm sure
that extends into Namibia Botswana
Zimbabwe Mozambique and probably up into
Malawi Zambia area but I don't think
they go anywhere else
very common in conservation areas
obviously they require an abundance of
food in the form of rodents scrub hares
look how easily it can look all the way
back here but something James is able to
do very well in the seat something I'm
trying to do when talking to the camera
but haven't quite mastered that spinal
twist yet so we'll probably seen how
James does it just effortlessly Dave is
having a chuckle so you can hear all the
alarm calls there the rattling of the
birds it's a very good indicator of
something present and we are seeing it
now there is the owl you can get that
with smaller owls as well as well as
snakes and even mongooses sometimes
small birds like that can give away the
presence of a leopard but more likely
something like a caracal or a wildcat so
following the alarm calls can be very
good and easy for finding the
camouflaged animals well David is out
trying to find things by night let's go
see how he's doing
right winter gets dark like this it's
time to look for the nocturnal animals
if it was in Kenya right now we'll be
right back in the camp as soon as
darkness comes in back home this is
different I love this I want to be out
here in the darkness and using to spot
Seb has told me there are two things
they look for mainly chameleons excuse
me
scrub hairs but seen if you lucky would
see our spotted friends and I'm hoping
that will happen and I'm here let's see
how our luck goes like our lights are on
we have changed everything now
oh that's a good question yes what
happened to our Swahili lessons yes yes
yes yes caste I haven't done I think I
did one in the morning not very sure but
that doesn't mean I cannot do another
one and let me see I don't know what the
viewers would like to know today as you
know on a Sunset Drive or do I give them
one word today at random of my choice
and let me see what I want to give them
it's a simple one
yes let me hear what the viewers have
won in my mind
let me hear oh you know let's see what
viewers may want to know for today I
have one in mind but let me see I'll
give you what you want but I also have
one for you and we're using or touches
now chanting on anybody coming out there
those animals Oh whose life starts in
the darkness like now scrub hairs
- could used to be pretty active at
night you've had them at night sometimes
and you never know has anybody requested
for one word any
avy usual two names of the elephants in
Swahili number one will be the temple te
and B table and the second one will be
Dovo nd o vo Davao so a B you can keep
either of this of those two or you can
keep both our torches are out looking
very very hard and definitely the
classes of the Swahili lessons will
continue again tomorrow as you having a
look on the chameleons and the trees
relax know-how is a night in Swahili and
we say o Saku Saku Saku
us I K u OC cool
all right to go to us there you go -
elephant you go tonight so elephant
again a temple all doable and suku is
the night tomorrow will tell you mood
china which will be the day but that
should be for tomorrow Devi
very exacting to use the lights at night
Steve is at a watering hole we are at
full circle watering hole and we got
here a little bit too late to check on
the geese I'm not sure if anyone checks
on them this morning I was off did you
see this morning or 7:00 this morning
fantastic news and here are the hippos
we have switched to infrared light
because it is dark now so what you're
seeing looks like a day shot but it is
not any we are in for a day yep yep
quite amazing and these hippos are
always so full of activity I'm only
joking I never do too much yeah nowhere
near as exciting as the chitwa chitwa
chitwa hippos always seem to be up to
something that side they are far more
than them and today they are three here
there's two there and then one at the
other side of the dam who is slowly
moving through the water and you just
see the wake there in the sort of middle
center of the screen there he goes the
sound of the water thick me in the
background that very high-pitched
whistle
beautiful to just sit and spend some
quiet moments at water holes water can
be very calming imagine being a hippo
that just spends the entire day in the
water now James is commenting on it
before but what do they think about you
know I've spent quite a few hours in a
swimming pool but I'm generally also
doing all sorts of things and that's
just the ownership Angie crocodiles go
in and out of the water depending on the
temperature if they are cold they'll go
after water if they are hot I'll go in
the water so it really depends on what's
going on with them and what they need so
you quite often find them sunning
themselves in the day but if in went if
the water's cold and the outside
temperatures warmer or vice-versa
they will regulate themselves by using
the water or the Sun or the bank or
whatever it might be so it all depends
on what's going on with them and hippos
are actually quite similar in that
regard and that's how they're able to to
eat so much less food than animals that
are very similar size and white
rhinoceros is equivalently the same size
as a hippo but yet the hippo feeds on a
third of the amount of grass quiet you
might ask yourself how is that possible
well the hippo spends its days in the
water and it uses the Sun and the water
to regulate its temperature rather than
us and the Rhino who need metabolic
energy for controlling the temperature
the hippo just uses the water so they
act like a crocodile and so they can
spend far less time feeding which is
quite a benefit to in Europe a big and
gain the animal like a hippo and then
they spend their time in the water so
that is quite a marvelous thing
third imagine that one-third of the diet
of an animal equal in size purely
because they don't need the energy
expended animals need are the mammals
anyway I can hear the Egyptian geese I
think they're actually just behind them
there Davi on the bank you might be able
to count them the parents are both there
one two three four five count them all
we're not going to make any assumptions
they're all enjoying a little bit of a
reflection in the glare blacksmith wing
calling so like the owl the hippos will
be emerging soon to take to the
wilderness for their nightly foraging
child of the universe hippos will
essentially use all males will have a
territorial area a dam a river or some
segment of where there's water in depend
on how far they go to feed depending on
conditions depending of his drafts they
might need to stop off in a pond on
their way at home so you can quite often
find hippos in a different pond than the
one that they normally occur in purely
because they've maybe had to travel
further distances to to get to where
they need to feed but generally you'll
get males that will find at an area that
is suitable for them
it's obviously needs to have adequate
water that lasts through the dry seasons
and adequate feeding and that territory
will attract the females and obviously
the strongest male will have the best
area and attracted the most females and
well then obviously sow his seed and
have more youngsters and that genetic
trait will follow on but hippos can move
and they can go and it all depends on
moisture and and the availability of
rainfall and do dams try up for example
there's been hippos recorded in June
and there's no a birthday at the moment
because there's no water so they have to
move in response to to the water and
there's a big issue in the Krueger with
the drought in the last two years and a
lot of hippos died because water was
very very minimal and they weren't able
to submerge themselves so we talked
about the runner and the hippo the thing
is rhino can still survive with us
having permanent water it means to drink
of course but it doesn't need to
submerge itself whereas the hippo and
all of its evolutionary adaptations to
feed far less in tirana if it cannot
submerge itself in water little perish
that is the way it works they're very
sensitive to the Sun and so that's the
one thing and unlike the owl david has
to use technology to see his animals yes
with all the calls going out here at
night either Big Bird spray like the
owls it is another new revelation
another new beginning for me in my life
to do a drive using infra red looking at
my Marita looking at those eyes in the
background looking of the black and
white have been saying earlier I love
this is something also very special for
me with impalas fear can't hardly you
know notice we're here isn't that
wonderful
and just to seeing them they are minding
their business not knowing you know not
worried by our presence it's pretty
special and Aiden you'd like to know
whether impalas ever break the hounds
yes the male's occasionally will do that
and this time around when they are
fighting for the mating rights or to you
know to to have the guards within their
area sometimes they go for each other
and when they do that sometimes they
fight and occasionally in the fight
fight or the fight us so bad and if one
miss times or doesn't get or is hit so
badly the horn might break and I don't
know where it and you come from but
locally here our antelopes and this
particular impalas once they lose that
horn that's the end of the story for
that horn but evil guess where you come
from you see Diaz Diaz is different the
Hans will be shed or once they lose them
they live grow them again in the future
but for in Paris once the fight as I
said earlier and they lose them that's
the end of story not once or twice you
might see an Impala with one horn out
there in the wilderness very good
question and in there I can see the love
you have for the wilderness very quiet
they slow down eating and now they'll do
more of listening of what's happening
out there because of the darkness we get
predators now either like Highness maybe
or leopards maybe wanting to come for
them
very beautiful eyes there I'm just
enjoying every one second here and as I
continue to enjoy this oh what a joy we
had having you on board we want to thank
you very much for having join us and
from all the team players out in the
bush in the full control
remember we shall be out here again on
the sunrise game dress game dress please
remember to join us for another exciting
gameplay from all of us we're saying
a very good bye for now